all elections important
we know in our bones this one is more
consequential and this is the most
important
election in the history of our country
[Music]
from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills between the coronavirus pandemic
protests over racial injustice and now
an open sea
on the united states supreme court
there's been a lot of news
during 2020 and we're also in an
election year so
we are bringing you some of the
brightest thinkers and writers of our
time
every single week here on quick take to
talk through why this is the most
important election ever
and we're starting our series today with
jonathan bernstein and neil ho
thank you both so much for joining us
today um jonathan i want to start with
you can you talk to me about
how rbg's death uh might impact this
election
well you know one of the real dangers
right now in american politics is this
question of
you know democracy and how secure the
american democracy
is and to what extent republicans are
going to
trample over norms and even laws
to get their way so you know one of the
things people were talking about is the
extent to which
trump may try to cheat the election and
that he's already tried to do things
which
essentially are undemocratic and
authoritarian
um that probably
you know could go through the courts um
you know he's talked about the president
has talked about
well uh after election night we'll have
a winner and it doesn't matter whether
there's votes still to be counted
um you know he's hinted that he may try
to shut down counts
of of legitimate votes um
after election night well if that
happens it goes to the courts if
any challenges happen to elections um
in the first instance the accounting
goes to the courts and it's possible
that it could go to the supreme court so
you know a different balance on the
supreme court certainly could have an
effect
neil popping over to you for a moment a
lot of your work centers on kind of
generational patterns and changes
and we know historically that scotus
hasn't exactly been a huge
inspiration factor for voters do you
think this election
could be different uh
yeah it already is different you know
one thing we know
when we look at polls going back to 2000
and uh bush you know versus gore
you had about 60 of american people
saying that this is an important
election there are important issue
differences between the two candidates
40
saying is tweedledum tweedledee today
it's different
it's about ninety percent saying their
fundamental
issues here only about ten percent
denying it
uh one of the things you've seen about
president trump
is that uh for whatever else you may not
like about him
he has solved the problem of voter
apathy in america
in 2018 for an off-year election we had
the highest
voter participation as a share of all
eligible voters
since 1914 that's a century right
uh and we're looking forward to that
same elevated turnout now in a
presidential year election
uh consider considerably higher than
2016 although
obviously the wild card is the mail-in
ballot
uh but i but i but i will say that uh
they're not a lot of undecided voters
left in america
so i think the the electoral impact of
uh you know the supreme court crisis if
you want to call it that
over the open uh you know the vacancy is
probably less important in bringing more
people out there i think
you know we everyone's motivated i think
it's more important
uh as jonathan was saying in the
so-called shadow daca to the supreme
court
right in other words there are hundreds
of cases already been
filed in states about voter
irregularities these get to go directly
many of these could go directly to the
supreme court supreme court rule on them
without any decision written down
they'll be doing it very rapidly perhaps
in the you know in the month
after the election and i think that's
something that uh the white house is
taking very seriously
and neil you bring up uh just the
importance of this election
jonathan i am wondering if you can talk
about why this election
is so important and whether you agree
with the assertion that it's the most
important election ever
you know every four years people say
it's the most
important election ever this one's a
pretty good candidate um
you know uh four years ago if you ask
political scientists there was sort of a
political scientist joke or a meme or
whatever you call it
um that americanists reacted to
the election of donald trump by saying
well you know we'll get through this
um comparativists the people who study
different
compare different countries know about
different countries they were
all screaming this is dangerous
you know we have to worry about
authoritarianism uh
and then the international relations
people were saying yeah i think we're
gonna worry about that when
nuclear war could break out well the
good news is war hasn't broken out but
the comparativists who worry about
authoritarianism
um they're doing okay in terms of
prediction
you know some of the things that have
happened in terms of
how the administration has governed
lawlessly uh are very important and what
worries people a lot is the possibility
that
a trump who does all these things the
first term and somehow manages to get
reelected
is going to be even less constrained by
normal the way normal democratic
practices work and even by the law
because he's gotten away with
breaking the law and ignoring the law
time after time after time
jonathan you mentioned some of the
division in this country and neil i'm
wondering historically have we ever
seen a time where the country has been
this divided uh
and if so how has that impacted previous
elections
well we have had eras in american
history
obviously the great civic crisis in our
history like the 1930s
obviously the civil war the american
revolution and going back
i think we also have the great
awakenings in american history a good
example would be the late 60s and 70s
anyone who's around during the uh the uh
the watergate era
knows how uh hysterical people were at
that time
so we do go through these um we do go
these periods i think it's important to
remember though on the subject of
populism and lawlessness
is that america was already extremely
dissatisfied with the establishment and
how it worked i mean we can't forget
how we get into populism right so long
before trump
america had fundamental problems with
how the establishment you know
checking all the boxes and following all
the rules was actually
responding to their problems and i think
uh just to simply say the problem is one
person in lawlessness kind of forgets
how we got here
um and look uh
trump has huge negatives going in uh
all honesty i mean we all follow the
future of the markets and so on but he's
probably gonna lose
but nonetheless there's going to be a
gray area and if he's close
that gray area is something that can be
exploited yeah i think
clearly since his voters will be voting
a lot more in person about two-thirds to
one-third
versus biden voters uh it's right i mean
he's gonna be he's gonna be looking good
if it's close he's gonna be looking good
on election night
and uh that creates a very unstable
and precarious public mood shift right
it creates the air of legitimacy
uh and and i think that's what people
find
you know dangerous but dangerous at this
point but we have gone through these
periods
where people think that we're beyond um
procedure law rules uh
where people are that divided uh they
think it's
uh you know my side or disaster and
i i think i think the polls
you know demonstrate that and i want to
go over to
jonathan for a moment neil brings up
kind of the idea
that um well neil you made the assertion
that trump may
not win um jonathan do you think if
that's the case
uh that this election could be resolved
peacefully or how do you see
trump responding to a potential loss
well i think the real question isn't so
much trump we know what trump's going to
do he's going to claim that there's
fraud
you know he claimed there was fraud when
he won so he's going to you know if he
if he seems to be losing he's going to
claim this fraud there's no question
about that
the question is what does the republican
party do
and you know to some extent what do the
courts do but you know
if if we have a situation where
on election night um trump
loses florida uh probably
um you know which is he's right around
50 50 in florida right now and florida
council's votes quickly
um if he loses other key states um
there's a good chance he may say i
really want it's a it's fraud and all
that
but nothing happens you know we have a
relatively normal transition except for
the president babbling and you know
doing what he
always does uh on the other hand if we
have a very close election and it comes
down to
pennsylvania and pennsylvania counts its
votes very slowly and might take two
three weeks
and we have you know the president
screaming and if republicans decide to
go along with that
then we have a real problem and jonathan
sticking with you for a moment do you
think that either candidate
can unite the country and potentially
kind of uh
soften some of the division and
polarization that we're talking about
yeah i i think i i would agree that
there have been these periods of time in
the country with division i don't know
that
at the ordinary people level this one is
particularly bad now we do have a lot of
evidence that
a lot of ordinary citizens have been
very involved in politics the
demonstrations are at record level but
you know in in the early 70s we also had
a lot more violence than we have now um
and then you know if you go back to the
18
hundreds of you know civil war area you
have a lot of problems
so yeah in the reconstruction era
and you know ku klux klan violence so
i'm not sure that this is
really at the popular level at the
grass troops level um that
being a problem if leadership
behaves itself but we don't know if
that's going to happen especially you
know on the republican side
and i want to kind of shift our
conversation over to the economy
um neil starting with you uh with
everything going on with cobit i'm
wondering if you think that trump's
historic polling on the
on the economy which has been pretty
good um might shift and whether you
think voters
uh could be kind of dissuaded from
voting for him
given the economic problems we have
coming up
you know that that's a good question um
i think
trump has surprised a lot of us on the
stimulus uh
i i have expected uh back in august uh
that trump would come out with uh a four
trillion dollar deal i mean
he doesn't care about the debt right and
actually go
to the left of the democrats and say i i
got an even
bigger deal you know and and basically
force the republicans to go along
or do something like that it's obviously
very important to his election
that the uh that the consumer has a lot
of steam
uh look we're already expected to be by
end of fy
2021 highest share of you know
debt to gdp in american history uh even
after world war ii
so i mean heck we're already there let's
just pile it on
and the next couple months are essential
to my victory so why not do it so i i've
been a little bit surprised at that
i think he feels that so many
republicans actually would drag their
feet
that it could get him involved in a in a
very heavy crossfire
and and he's mysterious you know you
don't know kind of why he does things or
doesn't
uh he's moving forward a little bit and
and
and uh uh upping his price tag
uh pelosi is coming down a little bit
but given the uh
the supreme court vacancy and and even
the fact that they
they can't even balance their books this
year you know this has to be some
emergency appropriation just to just to
keep government going
uh at the end of the fiscal year uh i
don't think it's certainly not gonna
happen
until until the the end of the election
so it's not gonna
at this point it's not gonna matter you
know for the election
and then beyond that we're talking more
about just how the economy is going to
do i think that depends a lot more
on the extent to which we're going to
have a um a second wave this winter
uh i almost certainly believe we're
going to have some
sizable increase in infections and
deaths we have no containment in this
country
we have no testing and tracing we're not
doing any of the things we should be
doing
so in my opinion we are going to have
that surge that will happen mostly after
the election
and it's going to be bad news uh you
know the temperature is going to be
colder it's going to be drier people are
going to be more inside
and even though cdc took down that
message this morning
aerosols do actually spread this uh
this virus so that's kind of where we
are it's not a happy situation i think
americans are particularly distressed
how poorly their government is doing
relative to the rest of the world
i i you know i i monitor a lot of these
opinion polls on people's long-term
impressions about uh america how we're
doing how their kids are gonna do
uh i have rarely seen even back in 1979
1980 with carter and stagflation
i can't recall a time when americans
were this distressed
about dysfunction of how their nation
works and i i do believe
that uh this country is ready for a a
mobilization
uh particularly younger people
particularly the generation you know
under 35
the the rising generation of millennials
uh they really want us
to get our act together nationally um
and
uh they they're really facing flack or
resistance
from older generations of individuals
neil just jumping in here you bring up
uh the crushing debt of our country
jonathan i'm wondering if you can talk
about whether either candidate
has a shot at kind of balancing the
budget in the u.s
oh i don't think that that's you know
one of the things that's really changed
now
um over the last eight years is that for
since about 1982 or so the democrats
have been the
party of fiscal conservativism they've
been the ones who cared about deficits
and i think that they learned the lesson
they learned from the obama years
is that there was really no payoff from
that you know they should have learned
that back in 1984 when
walter mondale said i'm going to raise
taxes to
you know eliminate the deficit and he
won one state um you don't hear joe
biden talking about the deficit
even you know as a as a thing to throw
it at
trump you know an obvious thing to throw
at trump because
trump's been if you think the deficit
should be low trump's been bad on that
so what you have now is basically two
parties
who don't care about deficits um so i
don't think that's gonna happen now i
personally think that's probably what
the economy needs right now
is high deficits so you know to me
that's probably a good thing for the
economy
uh but i agree that you know it's very
surprising republicans did not
agree to more stimulus it does show i
think you know how
weak in some ways how weak a president
um
trump is even though even with his
authoritarian tendencies
you know if the republicans in the
senate did not want stimulus
he wasn't going to push for it and when
he made some effort in the last week to
talk about it
basically everybody ignored him you know
and that's pretty much what's happened
any time that
trump on policy really deviated from
what
republicans on the hill wanted and we
are getting some audience questions in
while we're chatting here one question
is about
how um governors across the u.s will
potentially impact this election
uh and i'm wondering you know it's not
just the executive branch that's up for
grabs here there
are a lot of um various seats open
across the us so i'm wondering jonathan
do you want to talk about
uh just how local elections could impact
trump's chances
well you know there are always a huge
number of important elections out the
control of senate is up for grabs
technically the
control of the house is up for grabs
although we're pretty confident the
democrats will retain
their majority there uh state
legislative seats are incredibly
important this time because we're coming
into redistricting
so some of these you know gerrymanders
that have been around for 10 years
uh in some cases republicans did very
well in 2010
giving them a huge advantage in the
redistricting that went on in
20 after the 2010 census so this time
democrats have done very well in the
previous election in
2018 so a lot of democratic governors
this time
in states that had republican
gerrymanders and now democrats trying to
win back some
legislative bodies state legislative
bodies
so that matters less for you know this
election but going forward for the next
decade
who's going to draw those lines and
another question we have for you neil is
does biden's
enthusiasm gap have any historical
president president have there been any
other
um candidates that have had just kind of
a lack of enthusiasm among voters
oh yeah there are a lot of candidates
that
that americans aren't uh terribly
excited about uh
i i would say what's remarkable about
the democrats
is that despite the fact that if you ask
you know the voters on the two sides
who's more who's strongest for their
candidate who's more excited about their
candidate you know trump voters
definitely have the edge
but if you talk to democrats and compare
the two and
who is most sure to show up at election
time
democrats are right up there with uh
with republicans uh there's no gap
actually
on intent so even though democrats are
not enthused about biden i mean it's
just hard to get excited about joe biden
and think about how he's run his
campaign literally
it's i'm not going to take a stand on
almost anything except to say that i'm
not trump
it's been the i'm not trump campaign and
when people don't take stands
and inevitably invites a little bit of
contempt you know people and
particularly from his left
uh but i think even from moderate
democrats it's like you know isn't this
guy gonna have
uh you know his moment where he kind of
stands up
against either the left or the or the or
the conservatives in his party
but no he kind of wants to be it's you
know
in my opinion it's a little bit
generational i will have to say that
this is the first time
we could have a member of the silent
generation entering the white house
uh this is the uh generation that came
between the greatest generation and baby
boomers
they've been locked out of the
presidency now they're zero for about
i don't know 16 or 17 runs uh
ever since uh you know bobby kennedy and
walter mondale
uh and this could be their final moment
it's certainly their last chance
uh to enter the white house so we will
have someone who remembers world war ii
as a child
uh we've never had that uh and
and i think people see in that a kind of
a a moderate
compromising process-oriented
personality kind of a
mr rogers type and i think american
right at the moment
might be looking for that but they're
also very wary about it and a lot of
moderate democrats are really concerned
that biden is going to be rolled by his
left uh and a lot of leftists are
concerned
that he's not going to push you know
their hot button agenda issues
so it creates a lack of enthusiasm among
the partisans
and i know we're running out of time
here so i want to end by just asking
each of you the question um
why is 2020 such a political
and generational and cultural fork in
the road for voters
and i'll start with you on that jonathan
yeah i i really do think that
you know we have a sort of 20 to 30 year
um evolution the evolution of the
republican party
uh from newt gingrich especially on
that is a norm-busting democracy
a party that doesn't really believe in
democracy and that it accelerated
over time trump doesn't come out of
nowhere but trump
is worse trump is particularly an
unusually
lawless and constitution-less
president and you put those together and
you really do have
a lot of possibility of trouble you
also have because of trump not being
well versed on issues or still after
four years in the white house
there's a lot of stuff he doesn't seem
to know or pay attention to
so you have possibilities like you know
that he may pull out of nato
if uh he wins the second term he may
pull out of the world trade organization
um just because he wants to not because
of any kind of
sort of systematic you know thought
process
analytic thought process or where his
constituency wants him to go but just
because he doesn't like those things
and that's very rare in a president you
know you have to go back to
pre-modern presidencies for that and um
you know there's there's a lot of
possibility for that if he wins a second
term and feels especially emboldened
from that
neil do you have anything to add to that
yeah i would just add that
i think there's a long-term rhythm uh in
american politics and that is
you know after after a big crisis you
know we think of ourselves as living in
post-war america believe it or not
it's been it's been 70 80 years right uh
and there's a long time in which people
who've been through that experience of
bringing the nation together making big
institutions run effectively
and we basically bask in that momentum
right that generation is still around
they're running things
even the kids during that era you know
get to power
we're now beyond that uh that generation
has now completely passed away
even biden's generation is almost out
the door and history
shows that younger generations who don't
have that kind of socialization
don't understand what it is for a
government to make big things work
and bring people together uh things tend
to
uh grow dysfunctional uh the end of the
the nation tends to unravel uh
all of our national institutions don't
tend to work very well
and that brings us into a new era of
national crisis and mobilization and
frankly i think we're already in it
neil and jonathan thank you so much for
joining us today i'm so sorry we have to
wrap here for you guys to continue with
your days
uh but for those of you who joined us
and posted questions thank you so much
uh you can continue to follow bloomberg
quick take wherever you get your news on
all your social platforms
and we'll be back here with our second
episode of the most important election
ever next tuesday thank you so much